merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé des transports
et concernant le volet ferroviaire et
l'ensemble aussi des personnels le 14
novembre dernier vers 19h dans les
Ardennes Donchery commune d'un peu plus
de 2000 habitants situés sur la ligne
SNCF Charleville-Mézières Sedan un père
de famille et sa fille ont été tués
happées par un train de marchandises en
descendant d'un TER qui dessert cette
gare ce drame qui a suscité beaucoup
d'émotions dans ce Bourson entre et dans
les Ardennes mais en évidence les
problèmes de sécurité cette gare située
sur l'axe calebal le double voie
électrifié n'est pas équipé de passage
souterrains demande formulée de longue
date par le maire et ses collègues ni de
passage supérieur seul des pictogrammes
indique la présence d'un train croiseur
pour les voyageurs à noter que cette
gare est utilisée aussi par des
travailleurs qui font partie d'une
section les autres sur l'ensemble du
réseau national plus de 900 traversées
de voies
pour piétons existe monsieur le ministre
quelle mesure on visait vous pour la
sécurité des usagers et surtout en
parlant de moyens humains renforcés les
moyens humains de présence dans les gars
TER notamment et présence indispensable
des contrôleurs parce que là
malheureusement il y avait pas de
contrôleurs ainsi que dans les gars je
vous remercie